hey guys but what is this called say and
they say anything child say anything
challenge goes like this you say a word
I have to say a word and then whoever
doesn't say a word fast enough gets
taped it's a lot harder than you think
good so like there's so many words you
could say you go first okay couch skin
handle floor running cat thrifty purple
me fantastic you you says your kids in
the same word is worse the works show
the rule book no you can't say the same
yeah you're right getting the tape okay
I'm going online this time but please on
the water out tomorrow
no no eyebrows no I found some don't you
close it under the under eye you're fine
Friday okay book hey see you
computer IRA said you that was not good
I mean I said before all except continue
to how do you even sound serial volcano
voluptuous movie camera flabbergasted
tripod light flubber camera fish seafood
action CBS time back clock catch it
you didn't say a word after I eat so
much you can't put that in you might
have to bleep that okay right mold
cement but bird what a squirrel thick
not you're a nut
privacy karaoke scream brah crash socks
bandicoot glass Disney elephant monkey
world Milly glasses money years - what
how many oh good no no it can't breathe
it's because you have a deviated septum
oxygen thrifty help I said thrifty
already not that it matters I'll get
myself ah you're getting great Cape next
time Japanese gaming kitchen monitor so
Milla water second oxygen thriving hole
what your supply okay
the years and what I'm kind of I like
this is hard like because I don't really
get on the subject of things and then
just keep yeah a subjective like of like
of dirty thing no I'm so
sugar I'm rolling lip makeup you get a
tape don't give them the stay damp get -
dick I'm starting to sweat I'll put it
in the word
first fire bingo arm great sleeves
deodorant shirt wet undies attorney
Victoria Secret floor big Nike new
Reebok still the one girl I couldn't
breathe I had to like okay alright
core brush wrinkled chapstick hair melon
style hall thank you no all right I hate
it what do we want to go
hello Thomas them ran Cole why said
already
which isn't matter it doesn't matter off
take me up thank you it near the
speakers come expand a hideous troll oh
well I don't like a little oh oh
copy ed you're a dreamer floor milk
we've done yet but no are we so your
damn game then my game but this is your
movie oh there's my movie
are we done we'll do love more okay damn
orange kitchen Apple milk neighbor nice
knife no keys kill coffee you make slice
it tonight
oh wow watch my my version of it oh my
god all right I really hated it I hate
it I never want to do this again
well thanks for watching I will see you
later don't worry subscribe make sure
you like the video if you liked it even
if it didn't like it click like go check
out his channel I'm done I'm done I
don't want to be here
hey sirs I want to be here I don't want
me here look here oh good for me so so
squishy
grandpa tink pink well up next to him